Thanksgiving is over and you might be
heading out to look for that perfect
Christmas tree but which tree is really
right for you and your family
professional arborist Mark Chisholm from
Hickory Ridge Farm in Chesapeake
Virginia is here with some tips on how
to pick that perfect Christmas tree well
first up good morning Mark and welcome
thanks for being with us first off tell
us how do you know if a tree is really
fresh the first thing I would tell
people is look at the color if you see a
lot of yellowing or Browning it's
probably starting to go it may be dying
off pretty prematurely or walk up to the
tree grab a branch like so and then
wrote it through your hand like this
when you pull against the needles you
shouldn't see a lot of needles fall off
one or two is normal if half of them
start falling off you might want to move
to the next tree and lastly look for
flexibility if you can bend a branch
like this and it doesn't break and then
it bounces right back to where it was
that's a fresh treat how do you know
which tree really is right for your home
is there a way like you know pets pick
their people do trees pick their people
and they're and they're in their place
to live to for the holidays when I go to
a tree farm looking for the tree from my
house I'm looking for a couple of things
obviously you mentioned freshness size
is important but then I'm really looking
at shape and like density some trees are
sheared so tight I can't even get an
ornament on and some are so sparse that
they're not that healthy or look that
good so finding that right mix is good
but also I have a lot of heavy ornaments
that I put on the tree so I don't want
one that's super flexible and really
soft because it'll just it'll fall down
to the ground you can't get any presents
under it so again it's kind of personal
preference after you get the tree home
it's really important how you take care
of it so it lasts all the way through
the holidays so what are some of your
tips for taking care of the tree and
keeping it fresh
the first thing you want to do is like
I'll go to my garage I'll grab my steel
battery chainsaw and I'll make a cut as
flat as you can to keep it square but
also about an inch or two up so that way
you get rid of that dyeing material or
that dried up part of the tree because
it won't absorb water very easily once
you do that put it right in the water
and then to prep it to bring inside I'll
take like a small tree maybe tapping it
a few times or rattle all the all the
debris out of it and the loose needles
but if it's a bigger tree like I tend to
get I'll go grab my leaf blower I'll run
it through the tree not only do you get
rid of loose needles you get rid of all
the leaves that build up inside maybe
those random spiders and insects that
are in there or you know God forbid
maybe there's some wildlife in there
like that squirrel that's trying to hit
you right into your living room
most people will just say the best thing
to do is make sure it always stays
watered make sure it never gets too
shallow it'll pull a lot of water early
on so you want to make sure it doesn't
dry out so where can people go if they
want to find out more information and
more good tips from you a great resource
is tips for trees.com a lot of good
information there well thank you so much
nice to meet you happy holidays can't
wait to get the tree in the living room
and smell that good Pine I can smell it
like the it smells like the holidays
already thank you so much thank you
happy holidays